This has been a chaotic
and emotionally wrenching week in America.
And so we've been dedicating
our television time
to conversations with people
who really understand what it's like
to be Black in America in 2020.
Earlier today,
I had a great talk with
my very talented friend,
Sam Richardson.
So let's go to that now.
My guest tonight flew
across the world last year
to introduce me to the country of Ghana.
And it's incredible people.
He's a very talented comedian
who starred on the
acclaimed HBO series "Veep".
as well as the Comedy
Central series "Detroiters".
And I'm so glad he's with me tonight.
Please welcome a really good friend,
Sam Richardson.
Hey Sam.
Hey Conan.
Thanks very much for being here.
I know that you would express
a little bit of concern
or maybe trepidation
about coming on tonight.
Is that true or...
Well yeah.
'Cause personally,
I feel there's people
who are more eloquent in expressing
what's happening
or better...
A figurehead for the responsibility
of expressing what's going on right now.
Right.
But ultimately it came to the decision.
Well you know,
I am a Black man in America,
so I have empirical
knowledge of the situation,
and all I can do is speak for myself.
And you are my friend,
and I appreciate your idea
of raising Black voices to speak.
So I figured this was a
good opportunity to do that.
Yeah. I think there doesn't need to be...
I know what you mean,
'cause there are many times
when all of us in different
situations feel inadequate.
I'm constantly thinking,
why am I talking?
Not just in this situation,
but in a lot of situations.
And then I think,
this isn't just about people
who are specialists in Black history
or Black history in America.
It's not just about them.
It's about everybody who
has something to say,
who's experienced firsthand
what this is like.
So how are you?
How are you as a human being right now?
(laughs) Well I mean,
that's the question, right?
Every phone call,
every meeting,
every thing will start with that.
And it's like a really
double Dutch kinda answer.
Fact of the matter,
I'm incredibly sad.
I'm incredibly angry.
But at the same time I'd say,
I'm not surprised.
And I think no Black person
in America is surprised
or shocked by what's happening
or what's happened.
We've known this whole time.
I think what is...
I don't even know if I wanna
use the word encouraging.
But what is encouraging,
is watching the actual reaction to it.
Thing that has been happening for ever.
But now it's a time
where there's a solid fight back.
So that is an encouraging thing.
But I'm perfectly,
I'm sad all the time,
I'm mad all the time,
I'm filled with anxiety.
And I watch (laughs)...
I can't keep off my phone
from seeing what's going on.
But at the same time I try
and just take care of myself.
And that's what we need to do.
I can't let myself get into full despair,
I've to let myself get into action.
That makes sense.
Right.
It does make sense.
I'm curious because you and
I went a year ago to Ghana,
you showed me your country
that your family is from.
You have this really fascinating worldview
because you come from two worlds.
You've spent time growing up in Ghana,
but also Detroit.
And so you have this perspective
that is to me absolutely unique.
And maybe we could learn from.
Well yeah, it's true.
I grew up between two places.
I grew up between Ghana and Detroit.
And like in Ghana,
the faces are all black.
So I have no fear of being...
Of prejudice for this
color of my skin there.
Black people represent the wealthy elite,
the middle class
and the lower class there.
So,
that experience I have,
and then to juxtapose that
to my life in the United States,
there is no bolder contrast to know that,
here legitimately it's
second-class citizen.
Have you talked to your mom?
Does she have a take on
what's happening right now?
My mom is in Ghana right now,
as a matter of fact.
And she's been quarantined
up and sequestered
because of COVID and everything.
And the borders are closed there still.
But she's just worried
about my safety being here.
She's nervous and she's frightened.
And my dad is in Detroit right now.
Same sentiments.
The fear that exists.
And I'm not a parent,
but the fear that exists for parents
to have your children
navigating the world.
Where you know there is
a threat to their lives
and their livelihoods.
You know that's it.
That's just it's reality.
Can you tell me what your experience
was specifically?
I mean,
I will tell you one of 'em.
I remember I was at my girlfriend's house.
This is in Detroit suburbs,
this is in Berkeley.
And it was late night,
a drunk driver outside hit a pole.
Hit it,
crashed it right next to my car.
The police came
investigating and I said...
I went out side and I was like,
oh, officers.
And the guy screamed at me so quick,
Get the (beep) back!
And handled the gun.
And maybe in that instant,
I had forgotten what the protocol is
for Black people dealing with police.
'Cause I was like trying to help,
like curious to see what
was going on with my car
that was right next to this thing.
As if there was like a
bank robbery happening.
You came here for a drunk driver.
Yeah, yeah.
And a bystander.
What do you think my plan was?
And I remember I called my dad.
I had nothing.
I didn't know what else to do.
I was just like F it, I called my dad.
He was like,
yeah, remember.
And he said, remember.
Another time I was much younger.
And I went into a sporting goods store,
Sports Authority.
And I was walking through the aisles
and just looking around perusing.
I went to walk out of the Sports Authority
and this woman grabs me
and yanked me into this room.
She said, I know what you did.
I know what you did.
The cops are coming,
the cops are coming.
I know what you did.
And then the police showed up
and they were like,
we know that you stole something.
And I just couldn't...
(laughs) I was just fully confused.
You know,
I'm like 12 years old.
It's threat.
But this woman was like,
oh, I can...
This boy must've stole something.
And I have the proof of it
and I'm going to directly
get it out of him.
The police come and they're as aggressive.
They checked the footage
of me in the aisle way.
And I had taken off my watch
to put on a baseball glove
and put my watch in my pocket.
And the response
as though I had committed
an armed robbery.
And she knew that calling the police
was going to elicit that sort of response.
Like I had no quarter.
Wow, you're 12.
You're 12 years old.
12 years old.
Yeah.
This is in Dearborn, Michigan.
How do you contain that anger?
Do you know what I'm saying?
This is from my perspective.
But in all the time we spent together,
it's hard for me to imagine you containing
those infuriating humiliating experiences.
Do you know what I mean?
And so now in this moment it can come out.
But what do you do with that?
How do you live in the world
with that kind of anger?
I mean we all have to.
You know what I mean?
If we were all to show the amount
of frustration and fear that we feel,
we wouldn't be able to exist in society.
I mean to make it nerd (laughs).
In the movie "Avengers",
they're surrounded by the villains.
The aliens are attacking.
Captain America's like,
Hulk now would be a
good time to get angry.
And Hulk looks at him and says,
that's my secret Cap,
I'm always angry.
I can't let that anger make me...
I can't let that anger dictate my life
and stop me from experiencing life.
That's true for all of us.
There's no way that we can
see what happens in the world.
And watch these cases
of violence against us
and not be angry.
And these things boil over.
What we're watching right now
is things boiling over.
I've been talking this week.
Trying to look for...
Trying to listen and also
trying to figure out.
How can this not be just another incident
that we all process,
there's unrest and then we move on?
You find yourselves back
in the same situation
six months from now,
two years from now.
What's the way forward?
And one of the things
that W. Kamau Bell told me yesterday
was he said it's action.
Let's see your work.
And I thought that really spoke to me.
Which is,
yes there's a lot of talk
right now and talk is good.
And there are a lot of people
trying to symbolically,
and I'm talking about white people
trying to show that they care.
But then so much more about...
It feels like right now is about,
what are you going to do?
What are people going
to do moving forward?
What is your work?
And you gotta keep at it.
Meaning there's clearly a
lot of work here to be done.
So I don't know if that's...
Well, I think right now
there's a sweet spot.
'Cause everybody's at home with COVID,
everybody's closed in
and are faced with it.
They have to see what's happening.
And there's not immediately
after a distraction.
'Cause you know like,
go to work and then forget
about what's happening.
If you're bombarded with it every day,
you see what's happening,
you see what's happening.
It's impossible to ignore right now.
That shows that these things aren't new,
but you can watch.
Like now everybody's watching
and you just see how
close together they are
and that's constant.
These things didn't just start
when everybody was at home watching
their phones and that.
But they're constant.
So now everybody is forced to act.
So like moving forward,
it has to be,
everybody has to remember
how they feel right now.
Everybody has to act right now
and do as much as they can.
People,
we want to be distracted as much as we can
'cause we wanna keep our
world the same way it is
'cause we're comfortable in it.
But right now,
people are uncomfortable
and have to remember that discomfort.
It's called the pain for change.
How much stress
or how much pain can
you put on a situation
before you have to change it?
Like if somebody's pinching you,
a person who gets pinched the second,
this pinch doesn't mean anything.
So you don't move.
And somebody pinches harder,
you don't do this.
Somebody pinches hard you say,
Ow stop it!
Then you change your circumstances.
So right now,
we have to remember this pain
before all the other distractions
of the world come in.
And we're watching.
We're watching things are happening.
All four officers have been charged.
The Breonna Taylor case has been reopened.
We're watching these things happen.
And then we keep on it,
we can effect real change.
And that's another thing too,
it's up to white people
and all people to educate themselves.
The knee jerk reaction
of when somebody says Black lives matter
to then say all lives matter,
whether you are well-intentioned
or actively trying to discredit
the idea of Black lives matter.
Pay attention to what that is.
You know what,
what is it that makes you say that?
Do you really believe
that when a person says
Black lives matter,
we're saying Black lives matter more?
Or is it that the idea of
changing the system frightens you?
I mean these are the questions
you gotta ask.
There's nothing more frustrating truly
than going through your comments
or going through my comments
and I say something Black lives matter,
someone say,
well all lives matter.
Hey, but don't you think we know that?
Nobody said all lives don't matter.
Not once did I say a
white life doesn't matter.
Not once did I say any
life doesn't matter.
All I said is a Black life matters.
Matters.
Was it Michael Che?
In the stand up is like,
At least we're starting out at "matters."
That's the lowest talking point.
And to see opposition to that?
It's frustrating.
Yeah.
There's a fear of...
People wanna,
and again I'm gonna be specific.
White Americans want to do things
that will help
or make a difference
or sound like or be supportive.
And they might get it wrong.
And then they might get checked for it.
They may put up the...
Like with the internet,
people putting up the black tiles
thinking that...
And it's well intentioned.
But then it turns out to
actually not be helping
and angering some people.
And then there's a feeling
of well wait,
I just touched the stove.
I thought I was helping and I got burned.
One of the things that I've
been learning this week
is yeah,
be wrong.
Try.
Just keep trying and being embarrassed
or saying,
okay my bad.
I thought this was the right thing to do,
it's not.
Now I'm going to try again.
But my embarrassment,
is a tiny, tiny, tiny
(laughs) price to pay.
It's less than a mosquito bite.
This idea that people are
going to try something,
get checked for it online
and then get angry and say,
well I tried.
Shut off.
I put up a black tile
and now it turns out I'm
not supposed to do that.
So I'm out and I'm gonna
go watch "Real Housewives".
(laughs) 'cause I tried
to help and that's that.
Well they don't want my help.
So that's that,
I'm done.
Yeah.
What education do you go in
knowing everything about it?
What person goes into college,
knowing everything about
the college courses?
This is the time where
people are trying to learn,
people need to learn.
So part of learning is
getting things wrong
and then checking yourself
and then applying that to the next time.
I always say people can't let
their fear of getting things wrong,
or fear of not being able
to do the perfect thing,
or getting things perfectly right,
stop them from trying to do something.
Those are the steps that you have to take.
You have to get out there
and just make the first step at least.
And then let that encourage you to see.
Oh okay,
I can do something.
And then do the next step.
And then the next step.
People get the idea in their head
that they need to just go straight
into being Martin Luther
King or Malcolm X.
And just from zero to 100.
That's not rational.
But you need to do something
and then learn from it and grow from it.
The growth,
we have to grow in this.
To back up,
you took me to Ghana
for us to do a special
about "The Year of the Return",
the 400 years since the first slave ships
were leaving Africa.
And we went to Ghana to
experience that moment.
And we ran into this group
of people from the Chicago,
I think it's Trinity United Church.
And they were all from Chicago
and they were visiting
to experience this moment.
And I think it was Kumasi.
Kumasi, yeah.
Yeah.
And I started talking to them
and it was beautiful.
They were so fantastic.
And so moving to speak
to that I wanna make sure
we show that clip
because this is from a year ago.
But I think it resonates now.
Probably more than it did then.
Why is it important for you to be here?
You know it's a time to remember those
who came before us and our ancestors.
This is really deep to
see those who resisted.
That's a major thing.
They bring up those who are resistors,
who fought back.
And a lot of people did not make it.
So many people died on his journey
to be shipped and taken from their home.
All right.
It's kind of an awakening.
We've only been free
for roughly 160 years,
whereas we've been in
bondage for over 400 years.
So physically, yes.
We're free mentally,
not so much.
For me personally,
I'm realizing how much racial stress
I'm under every day in America.
I don't even realize it.
I don't even realize that
when I walk into spaces
where I am in minority,
I am constantly checking myself.
Here, I don't feel that.
When I am here,
I feel that I am at home.
One thing that is striking
is 400 years of slavery.
Think about it,
400 years.
How many generations of people,
good people that sat on the sidelines
and watch slavery occur.
This is a lesson that we all need to learn
is that if we see injustice,
whether it's happening to us personally,
or happening to our neighbors,
we gotta find a way to
speak out and stand up.
And one thing that's on my mind,
was one of the guys,
that when we went back to one
of the slave auction castles,
he said that you can either be bitter,
which means you can leave here weak,
or you can either be better,
which means you'll leave here stronger.
And so I thought about what that meant.
And what that meant
is that we've seen much agony
and we've seen much pain,
but we've also seen much hope
and much promise and much glory.
So we must tell the whole story.
But let us put as much emphasis
on the hope and on the glory
and on the optimism as we tell the story
so that people can say,
well there is a better day.
You know how eloquent
and how smart and on target
everybody was in that circle.
Everybody had a...
It was absurd.
A random group of I don't know
if it was 20 or 25 people.
I'd be hard pressed to
go anywhere in the world
and grab 25 people and
ask them all their opinion
and not one of them.
Not one of them was anything less
than this beautifully
eloquent and powerful
and (both laughing)
(laughing drowns out
speaker) teleprompter.
(both laughing)
Where is the prompter?
Absolutely.
Such a beautiful moment and ...
Every,
it's hard to say every.
But Black people,
we experience the world,
and we must be knowledgeable of it.
And so you caught 25 people
who are in a journey for knowledge.
So every one of them has been thinking
and expressing their
ideas so specifically.
And cultivating what their feelings are.
And so you caught them
at the perfect time.
Because as a Black person,
you have to be a scholar
in order to understand your feelings
of what's happening to you,
and what's happening to
your people in this country
for 400 years.
It's hard to ignore.
So like those 25 people,
you caught a sweet spot.
You know this is,
like I say,
it must be endlessly frustrating to have,
because this week,
I've been talking to either it's Van Jones
or W. Kamau Bell or you,
that this incident happens
and then suddenly everyone's asking you,
how do you feel and educate me.
Which is exhausting and not your job.
It's not your job to educate us.
It's our job to educate ourselves.
Of everyone I've spoken to this week,
you're the one I know the best.
And it's upsetting to hear your stories.
And because I know you
to be such an amazingly
sweet and sensitive person.
And I hate that 12 year
old or 20 year old you,
or 30 year old you,
had to go through any of that.
It makes me nauseous,
to be honest.
So you know me,
and this is just like a grand lesson
for anybody who's watching or anything.
You know me,
and you'd know that I
have this experience.
Imagine that for every
Black person that you know.
Yeah.
Whether you know them better than me,
or you know them less than me,
you know them to be a human being
and they have experienced this.
If that doesn't call you to action,
then you gotta ask yourself what would.
You know,
for someone who was worried about...
Earlier you were telling me,
well I'm worried about...
Had some trepidation
about coming on the show,
because all these professional speakers
on racial strife and
scholars have been talking,
and I don't know what my place is.
And your fears were not valid
because everything...
You've just talked about your experience
and it's as powerful as
anything I've heard this week.
So,
I really do appreciate it.
And I'm hoping...
I would like to be optimistic.
I don't know if you are,
but I would like to have...
I always describe myself
as a 51% optimist.
I'm aware I'm pessimistic,
but I wanna slightly
lean towards optimism.
And I wanna hope
that it gets us to a better place
if we keep doing the work.
I think so.
I think we have to keep doing the work.
I think like going back,
there's no quick fix to anything.
You know what?
2008 we watched Barack Obama
and everybody patted
themselves on the back.
We're like, yes, we did it.
We fixed racism. We got 'em.
(clapping hands)
That's done, on the next case.
(laughing)
And we were done with it.
And then nobody went to
vote two years later,
nobody went to do it.
So then we need to educate ourselves
on how the government works.
So you don't put this all on one person,
you have to work the system.
And if the more we educate ourselves,
the more we can see.
And there's hope out there.
We have to vote.
We have to become a part of this.
And we can see we can change things.
Like the first black woman mayor
was just elected in Ferguson.
Just happened.
We can make change happen.
We just have to do it.
And we can't be discouraged by voting.
And yes,
voter suppression is real.
Gerrymandering of districts is real.
These things are real.
But with overwhelming numbers,
you can't deny them.
And you say like,
you talk about getting discouraged.
I can't get discouraged.
Black people have been going through this
for 400 years here.
We haven't been discouraged yet.
So I say my white friends,
y'all can't either.
Yeah. (laughing)
But I'm discouraged.
(both laughing)
Oh yeah?
This looks pretty lame.
I am discouraged.
Sam has to cheer Conan up tonight.
(both laughing)
Don't miss segment of the week.
Sam,
you're a really good friend
and a great human being.
And thank you very much
for sharing with me.
And for making...
I'll tell you this,
I feel better.
Not that that's the goal,
but I do.
Just having you in my life.
And I really appreciate you talking to me.
Well,
I appreciate your friendship,
and I appreciate you using this time
to elevate, elevate...
I appreciate,
I'm gonna say that one more time.
I appreciate your friendship,
and I
(Conan laughing)
This is what I was worried about.
There it is.
Right at the end.
Tripped up at the finish line.
So well, and you (mumbles).
I think subconsciously,
you were like,
you know what?
Conan's an ass.
I can't, I can't.
I almost put on a professors hat,
and a monocle,
and it was like,
and my point is made (clapping hands).
And then just dumped it into the river.
Yeah. Well...
But I do appreciate you
elevating Black voices.
Well,
let's keep it going.
Let's keep it going.
Again,
thank you so much.
And I just keep thinking
about my favorite moment.
I know this is so silly
to bring up at the end.
But in Ghana,
visiting your mom at her house,
seeing all this really cool stuff,
you know the moment I'm talking about.
(Sam laughing)
Tribal emblems,
pictures of chieftains
that you're related to,
proud warrior stuff,
just amazing.
And then going down
and suddenly,
a bobblehead,
a funko doll.
Funko pop.
A funko pop doll of your
character from "Veep"
is between all this.
(both laughing)
And I remember that
moment just thinking like,
this is so great.
This is our son,
has gone off and he's conquered America.
This is what he's done.
(microphone interference
drown out speaker) for me.
All right,
you take care and I'll see you very soon.
All right.
All right. Take care.